foreign
[Music]
welcome to architecture session 218.
this is uh about the Google Cloud
Storage also commonly known as the GCS
which is the planet scale storage
Optimizer for AI workload and the cloud
first workload
my name is Jason Wu I lead the cloud
storage product team joining me today we
also have a SRI Devi who is the senior
engineering director for cloud storage
we're also very excited to have three
distinguished customers joining us today
searching from Priceline
Jack from neuro and ugor from codeway
we have a very packed agenda today I
will first give a little context about
the cloud storage why choose Google
Cloud Storage
then we'll move on to some of the new
product announcements we have
after that we'll have customers covering
sharing about how they're building
Innovative AI Solutions on top of cloud
storage
from large-scale AIML data pipelines to
gen AI model training and serving on top
of the cloud storage
to Enterprise AI with a delightful
customer experience
we will share about our future product
division for cloud storage with General
AI
and at the end we'll share some time
we'll have some time for Q A's as well
all right so what is the cloud storage a
quick primer cloud storage also known as
a GCS it's it is uh highly available
cost effective durable and simple to use
object storage
many customers using cloud storage for a
store and manage large amount of
unstructured data
there are few key differentiators for
Google Cloud Storage
the first one I'd like to highlight is
simplicity
we offer four different storage classes
from standard all the way to Archive
all these storage classes they share the
same set of API and provide instance
access even for accessing archive
storage
this is very different from a lot of the
archive storage products out there in
the market which oftentimes requires
customers to rehydrate the data and then
you can access the data which normally
takes hours to do it and for us it's all
instant access with the same API so this
dramatically simplifies the application
development
even for some of the very Advanced
capabilities such as Geo redundancy and
you know business continuity type of
capability
Google Cloud Storage offers a dual
region and multi-region product which we
offer to store two copies of your data
over two or more of the different
regions
with that kind of a multiple copy of the
data we still provide a single Global
endpoint with a strong consistency as
well as with automatic request routing
and failover failback so application can
interact with the Dual region and
multi-region product the same as their
interacting with the original bucket
reliability is another area which is
super critical to Enterprise customers
with a class of storage dual region and
the market region will offer the highest
availability SRA for both read and write
with the Dual region and the optional
turbo replication capability we also
offers the best RPO and RTO in the
industry with a 15 minutes guaranteed
RPO and zero minutes for RTO
closed storage is also optimized for
data intensive workloads such as Ai and
analytics which is a high throughput and
QPS
we also offers incredible scalability we
have customers today running expabytes
of data with the trillions of objects or
even from a single bucket
and cloud storage is uh
build with a secure by Design to begin
with and which offers a wide variety of
security capability to allow our
customers to meet their security and
compliance requirement
there are many use cases cloud storage
is well suited for
particularly for AI workload in the last
couple of years we have seen this
dramatic increase of use of cloud
storage for AI workload
with this uh
high performance programmability and
manageability which make cloud storage
well suited for these gen AI workload
both full model training as well as for
model serving
running data intensive analytics
workload is another common use case we
have customers using cloud storage for
large-scale data processing and a
large-scale data analytics where they
can get the high throughput and the low
latency out of their data
we have some world's largest content
providers using cloud storage for
storing their content and serving their
content from cloud storage
and backup and data protection has
always been a major use case for cloud
storage as well especially with the low
archive storage price combined with
instant data access all the time make it
ideal for a lot of the disaster recovery
and the data backup purpose
so next slide I'm going to cover a lot
of the new capabilities we're launching
to make the cloud storage you know and
you love even better
we have spent a lot of time to optimize
storage optimize the cloud storage for
the AI and analytics workload
in the areas of programmability we're
launching cloud storage Fields with
transfer for hdfs
as well as a pop sub to cloud storage
subscriptions
cloud storage diffuse allows customers
to mount and access their data from a
GCS Bucket from a cloud storage bucket
as a local file system
it's also fully integrated with gke so
that's with this it dramatically
simplifies the AI workflow for training
and inferencing
in the areas of our performance we're
introducing
a newer cache with a as well as a grpc
API and the performance Improvement for
Hadoop connector
a newer cache is a zono SSD based cache
SSD based read cache which is designed
for data intensive workload
combining anywhere cache with our unique
offering of matter region customer can
get this ultimate data placement
flexibility as well as the ability to
co-locate the data with their compute
resources in anywhere in the market
region
so this offers an ideal data storage
infrastructure for a lot of the
customers building a single unified lake
house on top of it
in the areas of manageability where
launching manager folders as well as
event-driven transfer
managed folders allows the customer to
group a set of objects within a bucket
and set permissions and access on top of
on that group so this simplifies a lot
of the data management for AI and
analytics workload
in addition we continue to invest to
make cloud storage even better for
Enterprise and Mission critical
workloads
for intelligent storage we are
introducing storage inside the data set
which allows customer to query their
storage object metadata
get insight directly using bigquery
with the auto class which helps the
customer to manage their storage and
doing cost optimization based on how
frequent the data get accessed while
expanding Auto class to include all the
your data including all the existing
buckets for where you have your data
stored
we're also introducing a number of
security and compliance controls to help
our customers to better meet their
security and compliance requirement
and the last but not the least we
continue to make the already awesome
reliability and scalability even better
we're launching soft delete replication
monitoring as well as the customer dual
regions for both Canada and Australia
in
soft delete is a key capability to help
customers protect themselves from this
accidental operation errors
I think many of us probably had the
experience where we accidentally deleted
some of the objects and then only
realized that a couple of days later
with soft delete you will be able to
recover those deleted objects very
easily
I know that I run through a large number
of new product announcements very
quickly a lot of these are new products
are available today and you can try it
and you can look into that now and some
of them will become available in the
months ahead
in the next few days we'll share more
details about each of those features and
we're very much looking forward to
working with you and having you try them
out
with that I would invite Jack to the to
the stage Jack is going to share how
they are building
um Innovative Ai and autonomous driving
Solutions on top of cloud storage Jack
thank you okay thank you thank you Jason
[Applause]
I'm head of autonomy infrastructure at
neural so today I'm going to talk about
what data and AI as scale and Euro looks
like what the challenges that we
encounter and how we partner with Google
Cloud Storage to resolve those some of
those challenges
so a neural our mission is to better
everyone's life with robotics and we're
building autonomous driving technology
as well as the customer robots for goods
delivery
we have been partnering with Google
Cloud for more than five years we're a
heavy user of cloud storage compute
engine and gke so my work for my Org the
goals is to accelerate the development
of autonomous driving technology with
the ml first strategy with a focus on
developer productivity cost optimization
and operational efficiency
so what does data and AI s scale look
like so basically in long story short
we're dealing with massive amount of
data so there are a few sources of data
like one major source is the on-row data
collection we have a fleet of vehicles
and robots that's driving on the road
and collect a lot of data and we have
high resolution sensors like cam
multiple cameras like lidars and Radars
continuously collecting data at about
you know a few hundred gigabytes per
hour of driving so you can imagine the
amount of data quickly accumulates
and we don't want to throw away any of
our data because you know we identify
the failure modes of the autonomous
autonomous technology and we want to do
some data mining to mine some
interesting scenes from the corporative
data that we collect in order to use
them for training or evaluation purpose
the second source of data coming from
simulation so simulation is a digital
twin of unreal testing so we use
simulation extensively to test our
autonomy software before we put them on
Road
so we're talking about you know exabyte
of scale of data here and when we run
large-scale simulation we're often
dealing with
terabits per seconds of bandwidth
um so when you're dealing with massive
amount of data we encounter challenges
like the cost of storing all this data
and also like the bandwidth throughput
for some large workload like simulation
and some security side of considerations
like security and governance
so how do we partner with Google Cloud
Storage to to solve these problems so
before we we partner with Google Cloud
we have on-prem data center that we
store our data and constantly we have to
fight with ever growing the amount of
storage and also reliability issues so
why we migrate everything to Google
Cloud you know reliability is is
extremely good and we don't need to
worry about it and the the scalability
is also also great at a good caustic
factor in this
um
uh the the other thing I think Google
Cloud did really well is a really good
developer experience it provides a very
unified API it's very easy to work with
so what are the features we're looking
forward for cloud storage so first one
is auto class as Jason just introduced
so Auto class is a way to automatic
medically manage the lifecycle of data
and you know move them to cheaper
storage layers so we don't need to spend
a ton of engineering effort to optimize
the life cycle of the data and actually
spend more useful engine resources on
developing our autonomous driving
technology and the second feature is
anywhere cache so we want to bring our
data close to our the GPU compute so
that we are not bottleneck on the the
data I O and have a high GPU utilization
so the third feature is managed folders
so we want finer A fine grain control of
the security uh fine grain Access
Control at below Bucket Level so super
excited and look forward to a lot of
features that GCS offers for us
so next I'm going to hand over to Uber
at co-way to talk about jnai and car
storage
foreign check thanks Jack
hello everyone thanks for joining my
name is and I'm working as a lead devops
engineer at codeway so I will be sharing
uh our experiences with Google Cloud
Storage with the integration of GCS
views on top of GK today
so codeway is a startup company we were
founded back in 2020 so we are like
three years old company but we already
scaled our products across like 125
million users all around the world and
we mainly focus on ai ai products the
sole purpose of our company is providing
these models as much as as possible
globally by productionizing it giving
some unique unique products
and Google cloud is really our main
infrastructure provider and since we are
dealing with uh Big Data uh with across
different products uh also we are
dealing with different AI models we
really don't want the data to be another
challenge for us so this is why from the
day one we're always using the cloud
storage but today's example will be on a
specific product called voy which has
the GCS fuse integration with it
so this specific use case is for the for
an application called voi and we always
produce mobile applications and voi is
an AI based portrait maker application
basically we ask some users from user we
ask for some headshots from different
angles different lighting conditions you
know the color conditions and we take
that from the application and then our
gke cluster basically create an uh
training pipeline as soon as we have
these images and training pipeline is
handled by a specific pod in the cluster
and this cluster is running of course on
gke and we are using lots of spot
instances with different kind of GPU
accelerators on top of that so for this
specific app we are mostly using a100 GP
accelerators from Nvidia
so the entire architecture is working as
event-based as soon as we have the
images we store them on GCS packet which
triggers a trading Pipeline and as soon
as training is finished we actually
create a unique model for each of our
each of our users so we don't have a
generic model but we are more like
dedicated more model for each of our
users
so where the GCS fuse at the value is
actually on the step four as soon as the
user has the trained model
they can ask some specific uh let's say
uh
visual let's say they want to see
themselves as a Greek god let's say so
we we take that as as prompt as soon as
user demands this and inference workload
starts at this time so that means we
need to fetch this AI model and then put
it on on a port for influence design
but the challenge is of course user arm
wants this multiple times not just one
that means we need to fetch this model
multiple times as well so we need really
like an abstract layer of storage so
that our stateless part can work with it
if you think about the like this step
four if you don't use the Google Cloud
Storage what will we do we would use
preferably acli to fetch the image like
gsutol but then we we also need to know
uh we also need to Cache this data on
specific parts so this is where the
challenge starts
if you want to implement this without
the GCS fuse we will probably use lots
of percentage volume claims that means
we need to manage this storage as well
but with the GCS fuse this is really
like a distributed abstract layer and we
just ask the user's model so that we we
can run an inference and as soon as we
have this output image we publish it
over the Google CD and to the end user
so what is the results out of this we
get uh as I said it really provides an
abstract layer of storage also
instrumentation is very easy you just
add certain annotation to your
kubernetes manifests
and you control access on the port level
by creating an attached a service
account on your pod this will
immediately inject the sidecar container
inside your application pod which
controls access to the Google Cloud
Storage itself
so you really have Port level security
uh this is also covering our security
concerns and also this application
actually reaches its first million users
within six days so as a startup company
scalability is really one of the
challenges especially for the devops
team but with the uh powerful
functionality with GCS views we only
focus on the improving the AI model we
have
and yeah with that being said I'm
passing section thank you
thank you
hello everyone
it's an honor to be here today speaking
at Google next
my name is Sachin Menon
privilege to serve as the vice president
of data and marketing technology at
Priceline
Priceline as you may all know is the
leader in online travel for over 25
years
with a mission to be one of the best
travel deal makers in the world
and this lets us fulfill
a purpose
of helping our customers experience the
moments that matter
in my capacity as head of data
my foremost aspiration is to optimize
our data platform for Speed and
reliability
concurrently we also wanted
a cutting-edge real-time data framework
that empowers well-informed decision
making
and personalized used experience
furthermore
it was critical to harness the full
potential of our data Lake architecture
enable large-scale machine learning
initiatives
and drive innovation
in our data platform modernization
Journey
we prioritized both proper data storage
solution
as well as efficient platform of
management in terms of operations and
cost
a criteria focused predominantly on
scalability durability and optimization
among the options Google Cloud Storage
stood out by embodying these qualities
and seamlessly integrating with a range
of services and processes that we wanted
to accomplish
as depicted in the architecture diagram
on the left
Google Cloud Storage serves
a central role as a data Lake
facilitating seamless
analytics machine learning and crucial
operational functions
a parallel priority for us was
optimizing cost
through integrated features like storage
insights and other class
we gain the ability to identify usage
trends
empowering informed decisions and
enhanced cost efficiency
looking ahead
we are focusing on three important use
cases or areas for using Enterprise
storage in Ai and Analytics
we are leveraging the integration of
vertex AI
and GCF together to create a
personalized travel concierge
to harness the power of personalization
and recommendation
and improve the customer experience in
all
we're also using GCS and gen AI
to search share and reuse internal data
assets which makes a team more
collaborative and productive
the last one the third one
GCS helps us with also the predictive
analysis
while maintaining the the
security features of certainly and
providing real-time insights giving us
better visibility into the data
these efforts
highlight that dedication
and commitment to fully leverage the
capabilities of our Enterprise storage
layer in the realm of AI analytics with
that I'll handle to 3jov for the next
Edition
hi everybody I am SRI Devi I lead
engineering for GCS we'll be shifting
gears a bit we have been talking about
so far as how GCS can actually help our
gen AI customers or AIML customers
here we want to talk about how maybe we
can use Janae ourselves to improve
storage so
we have been thinking about this for
some time and one of the big problems
that we identified was storage
management as you know a number of our
customers stored billions if not
trillions of objects on GCS and storage
management is actually a huge problem
we haven't just announced the insights
data sets which is like take all of our
metadata put it in bigquery and enable
you to gather insights using SQL but can
we do more we have gener at our disposal
can we do more so one of the things that
we have been thinking about is maybe we
can do something like national language
why is SQL why limit ourselves to SQL
the next one is why only metadata we
should also think about data metadata
logs your context your security and gcp
policies
the
then instead of just waiting for you to
answer ask questions we should probably
be thinking about the outcome what is
the user trying to do and kind of try
and do that instead of waiting on
checklist Etc
the other one is instead of like having
you run all these commands can we
automate all the repetitive tasks so
that was the goal that we set ourselves
with and at this point I'd like to share
a prototype that we have built using
vertex AI model garden and the duet AI
like AI safety practices Etc again just
calling out this is proof of concept
unlike all the other launches we don't
have commitments yet but we are
definitely looking for some feedback
um so you come into the GCS UI you see
all of your buckets and objects if I
will try and give you a snapshot of your
project which is relevant to you so here
in this case it talks about how
you know you have your project and it
has so many objects of data Etc you say
okay tell me more now it can actually
show based on your data kind of hey this
is the right way to generate the chart
right so kind of show where your buckets
are what are you where is your data in
each region
then it suggests some prompts that may
be useful to you right or you can enter
your own prompt so one of the things is
oh do you want to know which buckets are
growing fast
okay so you click on that then you know
it actually shows the buckets that are
growing fast then it again suggests oh
maybe you want to know you know which
buckets actually have no life cycle
rules this is important right like oh
you're not managing your storage so you
can click on that and then it actually
says I can actually these are the
buckets that don't have lifecycle rules
and you want to fix that
and you can suggest the command that can
run and for extra measure actually tells
you that this has added cost right and
it can actually run the command as well
if you give it the permissions so this
is kind of the experience that we are
shooting for
but what was more interesting this is as
you can imagine most of the data that
DCS has GCS documentation knowledge base
Etc
most of our customers actually have
compliance rules that they have to
follow based on their own company rules
so what if you can actually upload your
security requirements document and ask
in size gen AI how am I doing on my
bucket right so then it can synthesize
your document and look at the GCS data
and say okay based on your document the
that you have uploaded all your buckets
should not be publicly accessible that
means no bucket has to be publicly
accessible and you should have CMAC
protection setup this is customer
managed encryption key Etc so it
actually suggests what you should be
doing on your bucket
so hopefully that kind of gets you
excited as we are excited about this and
hope we can do more so we do believe
that AI enabled storage is near and as
you can see one of the nice use cases is
to combine all the data we have with
with us and create multi multi-term chat
experiences customized charts and code
generation and execution this is just
the tip of the iceberg I think board
will come as we go on
all right I think we are at the end of
the talk here hope all of you have
learned something about GCS
[Music]